how everyone I'm Nick from Pixy we
welcome back the lipstick diaries today
and goes to a classic makeup tutorial
for you with a really really bold lip
and for the lip I'm going to use
exaggerated lip liner and the only one
lipstick to start off with I need to
give my skin a blank canvas
I've got Rimmel wake me up anti fatigue
foundation let's give it a go hopefully
it's going to wake me up just going to
pop a few pumps of it onto the back of
my hand and then take a brush and work
that over the skin in circular motions
what smells nice and this foundation is
about medium coverage it covers my
redness but it doesn't cover my skin
completely which I like I don't want it
to look like I've got a mask on I want
it to look like it's part of my skin it
also got a lovely healthy Keeley glow to
this foundation which suppose is why
it's called anti fatigues it's going to
give you a boost make the skin look
alive who doesn't need that in the
morning I'm then going to take the
remote wake me up concealer that
complements the foundations and I'm
going to work that on any areas I felt
the foundation didn't cover enough so
anywhere that I feel like it's still a
bit more too much darkness so normally
under the eyes especially at this time
of year we want a little bit around the
nose a little bit on my chin I'm going
to take a tiny bit just in here because
my eyes dipping a tiny bit there a
little bit free my brow bone from use of
plucking my brow bones a little bit red
I'm going to take a nice brush that
really works that in to the skin and
just really make that part of the skin
it's not sitting on top
we're just trying to make that skin look
a little bit more flawless so that
there's real attention on the lip when
it's put on and then going to Pat the
skin into place I've got room stay matte
long-lasting powder really push that
into the skin so it keeps everything
into place so it lasts all day using the
same powder I'm going to take a slightly
smaller brush and I'm going to use that
as an eyeshadow base just powdering my
eyes into place there's not going to be
any creasing next I'm going to take
Rimmel mono eyeshadow and this is in the
color 0:02
millionaire I'm going to take a bit on a
dome shadow brush and just look back and
place that into the socket bone let the
brush do the work back and forth so just
add a little bit of depth to the eye
almost like a shadow next I'm going to
move on to the eyeliner I've chosen
scandalised precision micro eyeliner I'm
going to start off by drawing myself a
little line here basically you want to
look in to a mirror and wear your lower
lash line if you imagine that was to
continue just the waterline bit draw up
that's where your line goes get that on
both sides first nobody's eyes are
symmetrical so by doing this it's going
to make life much easier for you you're
then going to go to the tip where your
line ends and just draw back
now when you're doing liner make sure
the brush is on its side if you go in at
this angle makes it really hard to see
what you're doing so always on the side
now this liner is waterproof so you know
it's going to last all day then on to
mascara
I've got Rimmel super color 24 hour this
is going to give me volume and curl then
with my brows I'm going to take a little
bit of room or brow this way for our
styling gel just run that through my
brows just to give them a touch of
definition that's so nice on the cheeks
I've got Rimmel good to glow this is a
highlighter luma nating tint in it 0:02
piccadilly glow just going to take that
on a brush just run that over the cheeks
now I have powdered and this is a cream
but it's totally fine still work it
doesn't show too much it just lifts the
cheeks a little bit when you turn which
I really like
actually don't need too much color on
your cheeks we just want it to reflect
as you move next with a bit we've all
been waiting for the lip I have chosen
exaggerate liner in 1:04 call me crazy
now the reason I love this is because
it's a great color for a classic lip it
also has a lipstick to match exactly so
this is the only one lipstick in it six
to zero
call me crazy as well so it's really
really easy to match them up now they
pull out more of the lip liners to
coincide with the lipsticks so it's
really easy to use got twist up nib it's
really really precise and it's really
full of color
you can see I'm hardly pushing it's so
dense and true to the color so I'm going
to color my whole thing with this and
it's just given another barrier to keep
that lipstick on even longer it's an
extremely soft texture so it's not
pulling my Lipitor sometime
especially if you're a bit more chore if
you have to really push your lip liner
then it's going to pull the lips a
little bit more and that's when you get
that kind of bit where it misses this
goes on really smooth now I like to
cheat my lips a little bit because
they're not as full as I'd like them to
be so I tend to use a lip liner so I can
go straight across on my Cupid's bow so
it almost makes my lips look that little
bit fuller you can tell that's not
moving anywhere that's going to stay put
all day can't believe that's only three
ninety-nine that's good value of money
isn't it next to the lip I've got Rimmel
the only one lipstick in the colour 620
call me crazy
now we've you get confused as to what
colors inside they're all printed on the
sides we can see exactly what color is
inside so be sure to check that as well
let's give it a go it is the perfect
color it smells so good so this is a
four in one lipstick it has the color
which is really really strong the where
it's going to last it's got the moisture
so it's going to really moisturize your
lips throughout the day and it's got the
price at just $6.99 I think that's
pretty good
it is really moisturizing it is really
long wearing as well I have worn this
lipstick before and it does last and the
colour is super vibrant and actually my
lips are super dry at the moment because
of the winter and it's disguised it
really nicely I hope you've enjoyed that
video
I've really enjoyed doing it be sure to
come back and check out the next of the
lipstick diaries take care see you next
time bye